hello everybody and welcome back to this
may cry of fear okay all right I got out
unlock this door here I don't know how
to find this number there try this oh
come on that's not it
doctors locked the door all right no
Munden I just gotta leave my shotgun
here for a little bit while I go hunting
around for a phone number or something I
couldn't see anything through here
I don't know maybe it was maybe I can
shoot
those are waste of bullets all right
whatever okay so I got a snap key what
does that mean where would I use a step
maybe in the bowling alley area it was
there locked or down there
Oh quite remember there's no lock doors
up here I know that because almost all
the doors are open just double-check Oh
guarding something buddy there's
something over here ah more of your
friends get friends that goes down
what's this
ah staff course where hide it son oh I
need to go back and get my shotgun
hold on just a second God shut up you
crazy guys shut up shut up I think that
might be a little a little bit too loud
so even with the rain and people
screaming with health that's one of them
it's it's a little loud let me turn down
the sound of it
Jenna's to squeegee squeegee because I
don't want to have to shout and start
overloading my mic just for you guys to
hear me okay
now we're good that means an 870 or the
dark
what happened to the power anyway was
there no power on this level or
something damn guys screaming all of it
what the hell again I go into the thing
it sends me right back
what oh oh oh
don't don't be laughing or crying ah
huh huh where'd that come from
ah damnit inventory fall screw it I'm
just abandoning the shotgun altogether I
suppose what done left broken plate
all right yeah inventory now full
ha just you hey hang on I got a [ __ ]
hell
get to the gun [ __ ] I'm not another
one I got I got some for you and you you
there you go
oh look a window here yes all right
I don't like this flashlight as much
because every time I pull it out you
have to turn it on I was fine on this
drop
oh there we go ah ah see you
Walt Walt I gotta reload load it up yeah
I got dropped something so that I can
combine it right okay and they dropped
my gun just for a second up fine with
this area
ah v iii-vi i iii-vi i iii-vi okay it's
a coach for the door obviously box smash
doom can't get here
where's my gun oh damn it of course all
right thing never want to be easy on me
I unlocked the hatch with what
oh maybe was like a full patch the latch
right okay number five is reserved now
go back upstairs use a tablet to snack
the code side its head and then maybe I
can backtrack and get my shotgun here we
go five one one seven seven eight one
five five one one seven seven eight one
five one one seven eight but ah come on
alright maybe that wasn't it
is that codes way too long um Oh
let's try the second half seven eight
one five come on get out of there old
code no maybe I had an old code in there
before five one one seven nope that's
not it either
well I need to find the phone number oh
this is a phone number I'm an idiot I'm
an idiot
I'm stupid guys five one one seven seven
five of five one one seven seven eight
one five five one one seven eight one
five one six aah go home so bad
I'll just write it down because I'm an
idiot Bob one one seven seven eight one
six if I kept saying those slide
obviously I'm terribly stupid okay got
it
bad moon moon feeling seven eight moon
dick died
huh
oh ha ha aha
thank you friend oh thank you very
alright pretty good all right Oh too far
left there are seven seven three nine
thank you buddy are you a dastardly
demon seven seven three nine
thank you friend seven seven three nine
okay go to be Atticus see if the doctor
is there you got it
it sends m39 aha now let me go I don't
need this anymore right got the number
anyway let me go get my shotgun where
did that leave it oh I left it down
there good night damn it I need a bag I
hate not having inventory all my pet
peeves
noth-nothing victorious
is in the other room
wait a minute oh no no I left it in the
staff lounge I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I'll save one up I'm gonna go up to get
my shotgun then I'm gonna be on my merry
way I hope I don't need this don't doubt
it for something if I do that would be
terribly stupid all right whatever let
me use first let me use this not the gun
you can't inject yourself with a gun
Simon okay that that didn't do much okay
I'm guessing I don't need that got the
shot
with non shotgun shells
oh shut up guy I'll save here
come on Doc I got a bone to pick with
you doc ooh oh look another one plenty
of Glock Oh weird lost lock Oh t-33 four
seven isn't that the gun that I gave mr.
swing Dingley the doctor Friese name
Pernell it's pronounced name I got two
syringes here Oh boss fight you're the
[ __ ] did
Wow I do have to fight that I gave him a
gun oh I'm such an idiot
all right I got this shutting down like
a balls oh yeah
where are you ducky I'm teriyaki come
here pop your head up
ah ah I don't have to kill this guy miss
Brice um I shouldn't have given him the
gun
oh god damn I shouldn't because I'm
about to die Oh what the hell are you
how are you
don't kill me don't kill me bro Oh Kelly
all right whatever
apparently God dropped the shotgun for
now I'll just leave it here so that I
can pick it up whenever I need it
you know you keep their syringes
shouldn't be given the gun yes you're
[ __ ] dead
now where is that guy we'll take care of
him first
where'd he go I know he's gone
whatever I'll probably pop hey you can't
hit me [ __ ] that huh nope nope I miss
like a boss but no ow ow ow balls
come on that I work better not siding
guys aha there you are ads ads that's
you
[Music]
no I don't want to talk about it just
shut up doc I don't care what what Oh
across ah okay so I can't get two closer
he's gonna pull off my face which makes
sense yeah whatever
so if I run out of ammo I can't get in
melee but it doesn't matter because you
know what screw it I'm just gonna use my
shotgun right from the beginning
screw this a-hole he's getting a face
full of shotgun cuz this thing does
weigh a lot more damage come on doc
doctor bomb
oh damn just winged you come on Gummer
all right come on don't be such a pansy
come on out boom boom boom reloading Oh
perfect Oh nope not today cuz I'm gonna
get you with this [ __ ]
I'm the head perfect
where'd you go doc where'd you go
be on this side now ha wanker boom ah ah
I shouldn't give him that gun come on
come on come on bow fire me come on move
on
over here oh did you move over one or
two are you beat up their yard okay this
shotgun isn't working out too well
because I can't hit him with all the
shotgun shells
oh come on where'd you go let's go doc
doc
Wow where'd you go ah you gotta be
kidding
uf and a whole new F in a whole
oh well I swear to go well I'm out of
time
ah sorry about that I failed on that
boss hardcore but thank you guys so much
for watching I promise I'll finish up
this boss fight in the next game or in
the next episode so thank you so much
for watching and as always see you in
the next part
bye bye